surgical removal of the tumor is a
common treatment for breast cancer there
are a number of surgical techniques and
your doctor will help you decide which
is best for your situation in addition
to removing your breast tissue it may be
necessary to remove some or all of the
lymph nodes under your arm
before the procedure an intravenous line
will be started and you may be given an
oral sedative to help you relax rest
surgery usually requires general
anesthesia a breathing tube will be
inserted through your mouth and into
your throat and you will be given
medications to put you to sleep for the
duration of the procedure depending on
the type of procedure breast cancer
surgery usually takes one to three hours
the main surgical procedures are
lumpectomy and mastectomy
a lumpectomy preserves the appearance of
the breast the tumour along with a
margin of surrounding tissue is removed
in this procedure your surgeon will make
an incision in the skin and separate the
tumor and a margin of healthy tissue
from the breast with a scalpel then your
surgeon will remove the mass with
forceps send it to the pathology lab for
examination and close the wound with
sutures
in a mastectomy the entire breast is
removed this is usually indicated when
the tumor is too large for a lumpectomy
in a simple mastectomy only your breast
tissue is removed your surgeon will
begin by making an incision around your
nipple he or she will then separate your
breast tissue from the muscle underneath
and remove it for examination finally
your surgeon will insert drains to
prevent fluid collection before closing
the wound the most common type of
mastectomy is a modified radical
mastectomy in which the entire breast
and some or all of the lymph nodes under
your arm are removed in this procedure
your surgeon will make an incision along
the length of your breast separate your
breast tissue from the muscle underneath
and remove it for examination to remove
the lymph nodes under your arm many
surgeons use a technique called sentinel
node biopsy in this procedure dye is
injected into your breast to determine
which lymph nodes drain fluid first it
is these lymph nodes that are most
likely to contain cancer your surgeon
will remove one two three of these lymph
nodes for examination insert drains and
close the wound
with sutures in a radical mastectomy the
breast underlying tissue muscle beneath
the breast and all visible lymph nodes
are all removed your surgeon will begin
by making an incision along the length
of the breast next he or she will
separate all of the breast tissue muscle
from the chest wall and visible lymph
nodes and remove them for examination
finally your surgeon will insert drains
before closing the wound after your
breast surgery your breathing tube will
be removed and you will be taken to the
recovery area for monitoring
lumpectomies are often done as
outpatient procedures in this case you
will be able to leave
the hospital after several hours if your
surgery is done is an inpatient your
doctor will generally have you remain in
the hospital for one to two days to
monitor your recovery